this episode is presented by Dead Island
2 coming April 21st on Playstation Xbox
and PC
[Music]
from a showrunner who hit his stride
once he started being unfunny on purpose
and the world's best video game writer
and honor about his prestigious as
world's best hand musician
[Music]
comes a nerdy IP about a grizzled father
figure getting their kid with magic
blood to safety
no the TV show
no the TV show based on the game
[Music]
the TV show based on the game that also
Stars Pedro Pascal
The Last of Us
flashback to 2003 when scientists
discovered a nasty fungus Among Us
turning anyone they bit into whatever
work we're using for zombies this time
no infected oh it was infected scrolling
with infected we've been near infected
there's no infected out here the hell
they're right leading to a dystopia
where no one got to see Return of the
King in theaters and gave the best
chance at survival to people with made
up gluten allergies
probably a basic ingredient like flour
now embark on a nine hour escort Mission
across the desolate empty version of
America known as Canada that bring some
of the game's most iconic scenes to life
but strips out all the player choice I'm
sorry I have no other choice 90 of the
zombies you see it's empty and the
hilarious bugs
to focus on the central theme of say
with me now what if the real monster was
man all along you can't stick too close
to the source material though that's how
you get a house of the dead movie
I love how they cut the little bits of
the game in there that's how you know
it's faithful
me Joel a tough ombre from the Austin
suburbs with more trauma than you can
shake a dead kit at
played by Pedro Pascal an actor
currently traumatized by a never-ending
horde of daddy commands of the whole
vibe of the day are you new to it
one for you
all a happy family and think he's my
cool father yep I would love if
you could read a few thirst sweets no
dirty I need to stop calling Pedro
Pascal Daddy it's becoming a problem
Joe's the only man you call when you
need someone to begrudgingly smuggle a
minor across state lines for
non-consensual surgery but he'll soften
once he meets Ellie a girl whose
brainstem can cure the few sad creeps
Left Alive in this Hell's Gate she's
your everyday gun booze and porn loving
American
though what just to warm up how do we
even walk around with that thing please
get rid of it who could really use a
father figure if only to tell her that
saying every 10 seconds doesn't make you
sound mature
Moon where the are they already
just put me in the hole I'm
Gonna Save the world
yeah yeah man you're out of your
minds monkeys what the what the
you
yo shut the up you must have
missed all the street signs and the
enormous Forest holy
watch them saddle up together and learn
a valuable lesson that the real zombie
cure was the friends they made along the
way like Tess Joe's ride or die until
she did both
Bill and Frank the couple who lived
through the true horror of spending 16
years alone with your significant other
man you say Resource Management so help
me I will run through one of your
tripwires
okay okay before dying in the least
gamer way possible
then there's Henry and Sam brothers from
Kansas City who
all right Riley the girl who first
inspires Ellie's
Marlene we're seeing the Gore's face
wow they really are the last of us you
know HBO means business when they kill
off a nepo baby in the first episode so
in the wake of a few decently reviewed
profitable game adaptations get ready
for a whole lot more of them and enjoy
the ride Gamers because now you get to
spoil what's going to happen without
having to uh read a book as Last of Us
pushes the relentlessly Bleak zombie
genre to its absolute limits kids die
Henry they die all the time we're the
only way to keep your sanity is to take
joy in The Simple Pleasures
or failing That You Gotta Laugh for some
stale unfunny puns people are making
apocalypse jokes like there's no
tomorrow
[Music]
too soon no it's topical I stayed up all
night no wonder where the sun went and
then it dawned on me why did the
Scarecrow get an award
because he was outstanding in his field
a series relying on puns is a key source
of humor I can't even imagine being part
of something like that
starring
zaddy daycare how Bella got her rude
back I Kissed A shroom and I hate it
Luigi Nick offers man A Home of all the
Trap holes and all the compounds in the
world he falls into mine stop
collaborate and listen full metal Yellow
Jacket Mall Walker now eat this bread
for it is the body of Christ and eat
this meat for it is the body of George
Joel and Ellie Prime where's the cake
the cake is a lie Elite gamer tactics
how do I play Smash the buttons Jordan
Peterson when his pill bottle has a
childproof cap not today you knew World
Order jackpot
fast travel how about that made it in
five days easy days absolutely chowing
down
[Music]
what am I even eating that is 20 year
old Chef Boyardee ravioli
I actually agree
what the really bad wakeups
[Music]
eyes on me
the fireflies
took most of the night
I'm exhausted God damn it and serious
abdomen injuries move your hand baby
we gotta get you inside
you all talk it through but please
remember that I'm bleeding out
The Last of Us all cutscenes 4K
hey I think someone set the series on
easy mode these actors AI is way off
this episode is presented by Dead Island
2. see you in La zombie Slayers coming
April 21st on Playstation Xbox and PC
this is not Toys R Us this is Toys R me
if this honest trailer is a Rockin don't
come a knock in